Olivia Wilde and her ex Jason Sudeikis
spotted hugging it out it's like in the
process of working now a source tells
E.T it's been easier for the two to get
along since Olivia split from Harry
Styles hoping to try and make you know
every year we got to get older and wiser
and better on Friday the exes were seen
giving each other a friendly squeeze
after leaving a meeting together in
Hollywood that's Olivia dressed in a
yellow sweatshirt jeans and sneakers
while Jason Sports an off-white hoodie
dark blue pants and a matching blue
baseball hat all gussied up the friendly
pick of the pair who share an
eight-year-old son Otis and a
six-year-old daughter Daisy comes just
months after Olivia and Harry ended
their nearly two year long Romance
their love served as a source of
contention for Jason and Olivia who
split in 2020 after a seven year
engagement would she say yes
oh God I mean sure I mean we already
have said yes in many ways but you
haven't like gone to the altar well I
mean that's very traditional way of
thinking about stuff
Source tells ET that since the
blit from the musician she focusing all
her kids and family adding that Jason
has been trying to be supportive of
Olivia and a good co-parent during this
transition and things between them are
cordial and going well and while Olivia
appeared to be in good spirits Friday A
source told ET last month that the don't
worry darling director is still pretty
hurt by her breakup with Harry Olivia
and Harry had a lot of love for each
other and had a great time together so
it's been an adjustment for her
[Music]
as for Harry our source said he's doing
his own thing and focusing on work and
Friends adding that he isn't too broken
up about their split but back to Olivia
and Jason yes yes back in August Olivia
slammed her ex for publicly serving her
legal papers on stage during an
appearance at cinemacon at the time she
told variety she wasn't surprised by the
move adding quote there's a reason I
left that relationship and in September
she shot down the rumors that she left
Jason for Harry telling Vanity Fair that
she and her ex had a very bumpy
relationship and in the end they decided
they could be better parents as friends
who live in different houses
and while the road may have been bumpy
based on that hug it seems like things
are smoothing out
[Music]